all right my name is Ted ham I'm the
chair of journalism here at st. Joseph's
College I want to welcome you to the
College this next year will be our 100th
anniversary so give it up please it's
[Applause]
clearly one of the most anticipated
excited events that we've had in that
century and I just want to say very very
quickly that one of the great things
about Brooklyn is that one day you can
be a delivery man in Park Slope and
before you know it you are you can
become a world-famous author and that's
what you have here tonight and it's my
pleasure to bring up Jessica Stockton
bagnolo the co-owner of greenlight
bookstore who's going to introduce
tonight's event Jessica
good evening everyone I'm Jessica
Stockton vignola as Ted said and we are
so pleased tonight to be hosting Donna
huzi coats in Brooklyn to present his
new book between no other means
he's gonna be speaking tonight with
James Bennett of the Atlantic so you're
in for an excellent evening we are so
grateful for this partnership with st.
Joseph's College which allows us to
bring you these events in the Brooklyn
Voices series in this beautiful space
that has a lot more seating capacity
than we do in our bookstore on Fulton
Street we've had a great fall season
already this year with Jonathan Franzen
and Patti Smith and we're looking
forward to some more great events this
fall we have musician Kristen Hirsch of
throwing muses to talk about her memoir
of a chestnut on October 21 and the
creators of the podcast a novel welcome
to night Vale on November 12 you can
find all the event details and ticket
information on our website at green
light bookstore calm so before I turn
the stage over to the speakers just a
few little housekeeping things first
please silence your cell phone or other
electronic devices and note that there's
no photography during the event if you
purchase a ticket to this event you
should already have received your copy
of between the world and me additional
copies as well as other titles by coats
are available for sale at the greenlight
table throughout the evening there's no
book signing tonight but all copies of
between the world and me have been pre
signed by Tana huzi coats please also
note that some index cards were passed
around before we started if you have a
question that you'd like to have coats
answer in the Q&A please write it on the
card we're going to be collecting those
and James Bennett will select some
questions to be answered toward the end
of the event if you didn't get an index
card and you'd like one just wave your
hand and someone from green light will
bring you a card we'll collect those a
little later in the evening please also
note that this event is being recorded
by c-span and brick TV as well as live
stream to st. Joseph's students here on
campus now let me introduce tonight's
speakers I actually had this whole great
introduction written and tana huzi
Coates is like no you're not allowed to
say that
so here's what I'm left to it our
interview of this evening is James
Bennett who's the president and
editor-in-chief of the Atlantic he'll be
speaking with Donna huzi Coates who is a
national correspondent for the Atlantic
he's the author of between the world and
me which he's recently received a
MacArthur Fellowship the book has been
recently nominated for a National Book
Award and we just found out this evening
the book just won the Kirkus Prize
tonight
so for the rest leave me I'm gonna let
the Tata housing speak for himself so
please join me in welcoming to the stage
James Bennett and Tana Hosie coats
[Music]
[Music]
hello everybody
Thank You Jessica Thank You Ted Thank
You st. joseph´s and green light for
convening us and thanks to all of you
for being here and for your interest in
Tennessee's work I think you wanted to
make a statement as you passed a in this
is my manifesto I wanted to talk about
why I wrote between the world and me and
today before I sign those 900 books
between books I stopped at a book Court
and I signed nearly 100 books that was
awesome but David there was a young lady
who's the book buyer there now who I
remembered from 20 years ago as a 5 year
old girl she worked in a bookstore
called vertical books in DC and I used
to be in your Dupont Circle and I worked
there for one summer summer 1995
literally 20 years ago I was a horrible
bookseller
it's just you know awful awful book
seller you can only love books so much
and be a great book seller right because
if you love books and you're deeply
interested in books in fact be be
interested in doing the things that
books do you tend not to pay attention
to things like shoplifters so you know I
wasn't very good I did it that summer
but you know I had a 30% discount at the
store and I probably spent about 30% of
my check on books you know just just
buying buying books and so you know I
was so good to see Sophie that's the
young lady's name you know I went
upstairs and I was looking through some
some some of you know just the books
that they had there and I saw it this
book which is so important to me and
it's a book of poetry by this woman our
Karlin for Shane it's called the country
between us and it's a book of poetry i
read all right Jesus I might have been
18 years old you know I just got in the
Howard and I had been surrounded by this
great
immunity and kerala for say is such a
beautiful beautiful writer and she wrote
in such a way that I didn't understand
everything that she was saying but the
pain that angst and I have to say the
violence now reminded me of something
that I that I just so deeply deeply
identified with and she wrote in such a
way then I would read a poetry and I
would walk away and as I said I would
not understand what she was saying but I
would think about it you know and I
would go to bed thinking about it's what
I was saying other night James and I
would wake up thinking about it maybe
weeks later and even if I didn't
understand what she was writing about I
would think about it I just I'm in
trouble you guys by just reading a quick
poem of hers because I was just so moved
and I tell you this is all gonna make
sense in one second I promised you I'm
not just taking you through it so
counter flushes she um and also I got to
take any chance I can advocate for
poetry by the way which I think this not
having in the world
I was joking about if I could run it
j-school I wouldn't make everybody write
poetry for the first year just to you
know master the art of writing decent
sentences writing powerful sentences
writing you know really pungent
sentences kind of wish that she spent as
a young person you know time in Central
America and in Eastern Europe I had a
period in time where you know the world
was being turned upside down and this is
just a husband when I was teaching at
MIT and writing I would assign this to
my essay class just so they could
understand sentences this is called the
kernel
it's about her encounter with an unnamed
military official in an unnamed Central
American country what you have heard is
true I was in his house his wife carried
a tray of coffee and sugar
his daughter filed her nails his son
went out for the night there were daily
papers pet dogs a pistol on the cushion
beside him the moon swung bare on its
black court over the house on the
television was a car
show it was in English broken bottles
were embedded in the walls around the
house to scoop the kneecaps from a man's
legs or to cut his hands to lace or the
window they were gratings like those in
liquor stores we had dinner rack of lamb
good wine a gold bell was on the table
for calling the maid the maid bought
green mangoes salt a type of bread
I was asked how I enjoyed the country
there was a brief commercial in Spanish
his wife took everything away there was
some talk then of how difficult it had
become to govern the parents said hello
on the terrace the colonel told it to
shut up and pushed himself from the
table my friend said to me with his eyes
say nothing the colonel returned with a
sack used to bring groceries home he
spilled many human ears on the table
they were like dried peach halves there
is no other way to say this he took one
of them in his hands shook it in our
faces dropped it into a water glass it
came alive there I am tired of fooling
around he said as for the rights of
anyone tell your people they can go [ __ ]
themselves he swept the ears to the
floor with his arm and held the last of
his wine in the air something for your
poetry no he said some of the ears were
on the ground and caught this scrap of
his voice some of the ears on the floor
were pressed to the ground so I read
this and I'm I I always thought about
like the brutality of that poem and
Aniyah always stuck with me among all of
the imagery and all of the detail was
there is no other way to say this there
was no kind way there was no hopeful way
there is no way to make people feel good
about themselves at the end of the story
to say this and when I got a diploma
what I got in a colorful Shaye's poetry
in general and what I got out of my
entire studying poetry it is that you
know
it is the job of the writer to say
things in truthful and indirect ways and
in ways that maybe leave us in puzzling
places in ways that maybe you know leave
us despairing sometimes in ways that
make us sad sometimes one of the most
you know I probably you know pointed
questions I get about the book and one
one of the things that people raise
about the book all the time is that you
know he's not hopeful enough that it
does not inspire black people that does
not leave black people with the way out
with a way forward and maybe it doesn't
you know I think I would have an argue
about that but let's just leave it there
maybe it doesn't but you know I wanted
to talk to you guys about it because I
wanted to talk about the defense of
writing and the defense of literature
and the defense of art and the right to
create an act the right to create a
piece of art certainly out of the desire
to reflect reality strictly out of the
desire to show something to portray
one's experience in the most beautiful
way you know you possibly can and I just
think you know the desire to write
something that makes people feel good at
the end of the day desire to write
something that that that that is a
bedtime story the desire to give you
something that allows you to tuck your
children in at night even the desire to
write something that you know inspires
people to be better people that as a
strict motivation it's so far away from
why I wrote this book you know I wrote
this book to creator you know a
beautiful work of art that says
something that represented you know a
particular time I was in that
represented something about my
relationship to my son and ultimately
that represented something about my
relationship to my country I don't know
why I felt moved to tell you that
tonight but I did so we can proceed with
the program
[Applause]
sort of feel like you covered everything
[Laughter]
so we're gonna ask a few questions and
then as Jessica said ask some of your
questions once the cards come up some
way to explore a couple of the themes
from the book and maybe ask you to talk
about yourself a little bit more and the
theme I thought we ought to start with
is the one that you just a vote
yeah and part with that which is the
theme of violence and if you wouldn't
mind reading a bit of your own work to
start us off I'll kind of pick up with
that passage sure
this is the beginning of I guess my
political consciousness and I am about
it in this past about 12 or 13 years old
and I am becoming aware of that some of
the troubles that I experienced in my
neighborhood are somehow tied to you
know greater conflicts and greater
problems in the country I live in and
I've been told that all my life I have
been told that all my life but I'm
beginning to feel and I'm beginning to
see it for myself and not just see it as
something my parents tell me now the
questions began burning in me the
materials for research were all around
me in the form of books assembled by
your grandfather I'm addressing my son
here he was then working at Howard
University as a research librarian and
the Moreland Spingarn Research Center
one of the largest collections of
Africana in the world your grandfather
loved books and loves them to this day
and they were all over the house books
about black people by black people for
black people
spilling off shelves and out of the
living room boxed up in the basement dad
had been a local captain and the Black
Panther Party I read through all of dads
books about the Panthers and his stash
of old party newspapers I was attracted
to their guns because the guns seemed
honest the guns seemed to address this
country which invented the streets that
secured them with despotic police in its
primary language violence and I compared
the Panthers to the heroes given to me
by the school's men and women who struck
me as ridiculous and contrary to
everything I knew every February my
classmates and I were herded into
assemblies for a ritual review of the
civil rights movement
our teachers urged us toward the example
of freedom marches Freedom Riders and
freedom summers and it seemed that the
month could not pass without a series of
films dedicated to the glories of being
beaten on camera the black people in
these films seem to love the worst
things in life love the dogs that rent
their children apart the tear gas that
clawed it their lungs the fire hoses
they tore off their clothes and tumbled
them into the streets they seemed to
love the men who raped them
the women who cursed them love the
children who spat on them the terrorists
who bombed them why are they showing
this to us why well why were only our
heroes nonviolent I speak not of the
morality of non-violence but in this
sense that blacks are in a special need
of this morality back then all I could
do was imagine these freedom lovers
about what I knew which is to say I
measured them against children pulling
out in 7-eleven parking lots against
parents wielding extension cords and
yeah [ __ ] what's up now I judged them
against the country I knew which had
acquired the land through murder and
tamed it under slavery against the
country whose armies found fanned out
across the world to extend their
Dominion the world the real one was
civilization secured and ruled by savage
means how could the school's valorize
men and women whose value society
actively scorned how could they send us
out into the streets of Baltimore
knowing all they knew and then speak of
non-violence um actually give up maybe
you should give a little context for
this you write a lot about the sources
of that violence in the book and I think
this is a realization you came to later
that that is driven by fear right right
well you know I think in our current
political dialogue there is a separation
between what people call police violence
which were very concerned about right
now and what people call as far as I'm
concerned by the wrong name but black on
black violence and the notion that these
two things are somehow separate from
each other and when I wrote between the
world and me and frankly when I wrote my
previous book I you know I had no fear
of talking about the violence that that
was around me and in my neighborhood
with people you know considered to be
black on black violence that God is a
part of it that's that's a portion of
the oppression I think when people look
at african-americans in the neighborhood
there is a way in which they look at our
mannerisms the way we walk the way we
talk the way we pose some
practices the violence itself and what
they see is rage and what they see is
this need to express power they see
machismo and that's probably what I saw
as a young person too but by the time I
was older and by the time I could look
at young boys at about the age I was you
know I could see something else and what
I saw was fear and the violence I talked
about the violence that that is an
enabler is the product of that fear and
when I rode between the world I mean I
was like really really important to say
I'm it's really important to alter this
narrative of rage which is in itself the
specter of white fear by the way that
that sort of ambition of love with black
people being angry it is the shadow of
white fear but I was concerned with
black fit because I think when you do
that you you can soften the people you
know we begin to have humanity then you
know we are just so often portrayed is
like you know and vulnerable you know
not being scared not not really you know
anybody else would have you know who
lived in those sorts of neighborhoods
but we weren't afraid we are afraid and
I just thought that was really really
important the same it's a pretty
powerful thing you say that as a child
when you were shepherded into these
movies that the heroes of the civil
rights movement struck you as as
ridiculous yeah I don't know if you
include King in that list or not at the
time I did at the time how do you think
about them now um I think of them as
supremely heroic no I think of them as
incredibly heroic I think of them as
having access to a kind of morality that
that I don't and I think a lot of that
is because I don't have a routing in the
church and so even even the logic of it
I can't I think like for instance I
think a lot of it is rooted in the
belief and their afterlife which I don't
I don't share I think a lot of it is
rooted in the notion of a supreme god of
justice you know in law and morality
which I don't particularly share but I
think in spite of that you know
you know I you can't watch the end of
the Selma campaign and and see dr. King
you know give that how long not lost we
did not be terribly terribly moved you
can't watch the last speech he gave you
know before he would die the next day
when he is sick and so tired or
literally falling away from the
microphone you know it is the
mountaintop speech and not be terribly
terribly moved these are people who
every you know willingly day in and day
out gave of their bodies you know I mean
put their lives you know which is to my
mind all you have put their lives on the
line you know for a world that they
would not necessarily see at the same
time I think um whereas the broader
country feels celebratory about that I
you know you want talking about rage I
feel incredible anger at that because in
my mind it never should have had to
happen when I see you know President
Obama this is not like President Obama
so it's not you know anything personal
about him but when I see the president
you know going to Selma you know in
commemorating Bloody Sunday I just it
bothers me because I feel like I had you
know I had the president had the
government been doing its job at that
time Bloody Sunday would never have been
necessary it never should have happened
in the first place Martin Luther King
was killed and the Voting Rights Act the
Civil Rights Act the housing at those
things don't make it okay to he was
killed for me I don't feel that that his
death is redeemed by those things and so
it is not even so much to sacrifice it
is not even so much the ethic of
non-violence which I get it's not so
much the tactic in our attire which I
get now but it is the celebration of it
by people who don't necessarily even
embrace those values themselves and you
know I find that bothersome I do you
think about the relationship between
violence and political progress
generally
American history I mean Baldwin yeah
we're talking about James Baldwin last
night and one of the things he wrote I
think in the far next time is that
blacks were that that heroism and
violence were generally linked in
American history except yeah that's it
that's it well I think um it's colorful
say there's no other way to say this I
don't think there's really you can point
to political progress in terms of black
people without looking at violence now
they're people who say that in the kind
who have said that in the past and a
kind of you know Eldridge Cleaver s
braggadocio so the way I don't mean that
in fact I think it's a great tragedy I
mean it's not even just true black you
maybe that's true you know any state
anywhere but I mean it is not you know
through his I you know say in a book
through ice cream socials and picnics
that emancipation for African Americans
in this country came 600,000 people died
it was through great violence and part
of the way that war was won once it got
really really crucial was by listing
former slaves to do great violence
against you know slave masters that that
and backwards and the other way to
that's how he managed to patient came
there's one way of looking at the civil
rights movement that says you know that
focuses in on a protest and I think the
protests are really really important but
you can't really separate the history of
civil rights movement from World War two
and from you know Americans seeing
racism taking to its most lethal ends
you can't separate it from the Cold War
you know you can't separate the Freedom
Rides from bobby kennedy you know
watching the Freedom Rides I'm saying
you know we're out here talking about
democracy this embarrasses us you know
this has to get dealt with you know and
the focused on the civil rights movement
you know knew that and so I don't take
any joy like out of this but it's hard
for me to see moment of political
progress for african-americans in this
country and to separate them from
violence and again I don't mean an inny
sort of heroic or bragging
you know practical CEO and anything like
that at all
but violence is part of politics I think
so in in that context how do you
understand the violence that we saw in
Baltimore and Ferguson over the course
the last year oh I don't know yet I
don't know yet I don't want to say this
because I don't know it to be true but I
think it is possible I think it's
possible that the violence is part of
why those officers got you know ended up
being prosecuted I think that that's
possible
you know we know very much that you know
there's a common myth that for instance
the riots that happened in the 1960s
resulted in nothing and we know very
much that Lyndon Johnson when he passed
the house now he talks about the riots
you know there is political action that
that that results from from that sort of
thing that doesn't make rioting a good
thing you know any more than it makes
you know climate change a good thing
anyone it makes hunger a good thing you
know rioting is something that happens
when you put people under you know
enormous political pressure or when your
team doesn't win the national
championship you know I mean when they
fill themselves when they fill up their
backs up against the wall and if you
shoot at states often respond to that
again it does not make riding a good
thing it's a statement of fact and not
not a statement of values and so if I
were out there you know I certainly
would not urge anybody that you know to
take to the streets or to burn any sort
of you know see what to do any sort of
violence just you know on a moral level
I don't think it's correct I don't think
the destruction of other people's stuff
is Africa right I don't they can never
be justified I don't think you know the
potential for the loss of life can ever
be correct you know and no matter what
the system does you as an individual
have a moral responsibility to deal with
that at the same time at the same time
when I hear people who have power you
know who have some amount of stake in
the kind of
that has regularly characterized
Baltimore from the time I was a child
and before that stand up in front of
podiums and dismiss people with thugs or
whatever it's just again it bothers me
it greatly greatly bothers me you know
so there's that we're still in it though
you know I'll have more you know develop
notions once we're out of it but we're
still in it all right well this is
probably a question to get it your
method as a writer yes a little bit
shifting gears I'd love to hear you talk
a little bit about if you would about
the how you came to write this book you
said to an interviewer over the summer
that you couldn't one of the wonderful
things in this book if you haven't read
it yet is it's partly the the story of
your becoming conscious as you put it in
stages I'm growing up and then at Howard
and then after that but despite all of
your reading and everything all your
thinking and reporting you said that as
of 2007-2008 you would not have written
this book and that you were radicalized
five years after that so what is it that
happened that brought it about well you
know I had I was very fortunate to be
hired by James Bennett to work at the
other things that's not what I was
product
but this is real I mean this is actually
this is actually true it was another
officiate for that answer
when I was hired it was an age you know
I began writing for a magazine I think
had that was interested in ideas and was
interested in big notions and you know
putting its footprint on things and said
a night that allowed me to expand how I
thought about things the second thing is
my primary job was to you know fill a
blog space with thoughts and notions and
I took that as an excuse to go back and
study some things and to read some
things and then to write about what I
was reading and people would come and
they would read the stuff that I was
writing and then they would comment on
it they would say you should read this
you should check out that I had always
been interested in history but probably
the past seven years a period of seven
years had been you know particularly
intense for me for the amount of reading
I did and um african-americans who are
in public and are somehow affiliated
with politics carry this burden of
having to be uplifting you know having
to say something positive to the youth
in the most thin possible way of that
definition by the way historians have no
such burden you know that's not how
historians it judge they write their
work and as sad as it is most people
don't read it anyway so they just write
you know I don't care it's not have any
impact anyway you know but she got fries
though you know and I obviously I was
you know I always say this but it's like
people say that you know my work is
hopeless my work is pessimistic you
should go spend some time in the history
department yeah I was back there when I
was signing those books I was listening
to I had on an audiobook with me and I'm
going through but I still I'm a finished
soon I'm only a few chapters out
but Barbara Tishman is a distant mirror
and it's a history of the of the 14th
century in Europe you know we're talking
about the Black Death and some 100 Years
War some boats schism in the church
weotot me you you think you know what's
happening on the streets of Baltimore
Sun you we talk about people taking
petty offense and then challenging folks
to joust duels with battle axes I mean
is what these guys are they literally
would have gang fights like you get 50
of your boys your biggest Nobles and I
get 50 of my boys and we're gonna meet
out here we're gonna do this that mean
they they talk they call the champions
right that's or things they have 50 of
your best champ you know they put it in
this aisle but it's really the same
thing it's no different that you stepped
on my sneakers or you said this to my
grandma
it's the same sort of language this is
not uplifting material
what is deeply enlightening material its
value don't you feel like you know more
about the world and I not in and of
itself is a beautiful thing because for
me you know and then again maybe this is
the absence of religion I um
accept it and I have accepted that you
know my life is precious you know all
life is precious can be snuffed out at
any moment and then that will be it and
the time that I have here you know I
just want to understand as much as I can
you know and so to understand it is for
me and in and of itself a gift but I had
this great period at the Atlantic way
you know I just spent a lot of time
trying to understand things and that put
me in a difficult position when it came
time there right because it's like again
you don't have any certain prominence
you're expected to save certain things
but the people in the back of my head
talk very very differently about the
world you know and they talk very very
differently about you know the fate of
what you know I just you know I make
statement sometimes like I'll say you
know listen I have some doubts so I
would not be surprised if you know white
supremacy was with this country you know
for the entirety of its lifespan if
people said oh my god Horus how can you
say that and I say listen go poll 100
historians who study race and white
supremacy is gonna tax them ask them if
they would be surprised by that I'm
living in France right now and France
has been dogged by anti-semitism for
what thousand years or something like
that you know what sort of expectation
is this for me cuz I'm taking too long
oh no those that it could come to the
questions okay so
I think that it just changes your angle
you know I got something out of the
amount of radicalizes right it's just I
think it's switched my orientation quite
a bit do you think we can I mean yeah if
thanks for talking about the way you
work cuz it is it is I think really
better than any writer I know you do
this unbelievable job of connecting
what's happening today to what's
happened over a long period of time and
you're traveling back and forth
constantly between narratives what we
see around us what you see around us and
and it's links to the recent past and
the deep past but from your study of
history or you you say there's lots of
reasons a lot of it is hopeless but do
you see areas where we have managed to
escape or overcome work yes I mean you
know I think um obviously 50 years ago
we could not have had an
african-american president I think what
that means is we have we are prepared to
have a society we end with individual
african-americans through some mix of
hard work talent and a lot of luck
achieve great things I think we're okay
with that right now
that is our progress we obviously don't
have enslavement anymore that's gone but
that mean this goes back to your earlier
question when you think about how did we
get there
you know I see people being killed you
know and so it is like even like
whatever you know sort of progress is
the shadow attack is it's great violence
and what does that mean about our fate I
mean what does that mean about societies
in general forget just America what does
that mean about human societies period I
don't know all right thank you for these
so go to the audience questions
the first one's a good one I think do
you think between the world and me has
had a bigger impact on the world or on
your son do you wish it were the other
way around
impact on my son the book is not it's
not like I mean the book is written as a
ladder to him but nothing it is actually
new to him yeah me everything in here is
pretty much stuff that I've said to him
already so it had no impact on him then
he tried the book several times but it's
just okay daddy rights okay what about
that comic book though your back is had
on the world I do something that fit for
that you did a little bit of this at the
top but do you have any advice for
students and young people who want to do
what you do
yes yes yes read read read write read
rinse repeat that's the job that really
is the job and live you know just go out
go out into the world and live but I
think um I think you should probably
shouldn't think too much about getting
published I mean if you get published
that's great it's a lot easier now think
a lot about getting better avoid any
trappings of glamour avoid any ambition
towards glamour get adjusted to the
loneliness and the misery and the
horribleness are sitting by yourself and
facing a blank page and if you can
adjust yourself to that there are all
sorts of beautiful things that will come
after a long time after
but they will come they say they will
come but I think you really have to
adjust yourself to this sort of almost
Spartan existence of being a writer you
know yeah I think I'm probably not the
best friend I could be you know largely
you know because of where my commitments
are and you'll find yourself having to
sacrifice you know that I think don't
drink too much don't I mean this is real
this is real me it's not moral advice
this is because writing is a job it's a
thing that has to get done and if you
are out you know till 2:00 in the
morning and you're not getting up till
2:00 and aft and afternoon you've lost
time for practicing your craft don't get
on drugs avoid drugs probably
again it's not it's not a moral argument
I mean but the sight of your mind the
space of your mind is actually very very
important when you're writing now if you
want to you know do a bunch of drugs and
drink you know go do something else and
that's fine but if you're gonna be a
writer you know like your mind and your
clarity and your vision is so so
important
for me I actually found again this is
this sounds overly moral but I actually
found monogamy and having a child at a
very young age to be crucial it routed
me and disciplined me and put me in a
place I could not go out and do some of
the things that people my age we're not
you know my son was born I was 24 um I
could not go out and do you know some of
the things that a lot of you know my
friends and their 20s we're doing but
that actually meant that I had more time
to write there's nothing else to do you
know kids taking a nap what are you
gonna do you gotta write you know I
think like committing yourself to it you
know in committing yourself to the
clarity of it
I think is hugely important I'm trying
to extract it and there are a number of
questions on similar themes so in a
number of them past versions of this
particular question which is in
searching quotes in the internet I found
a quote by you that says but race is the
child of racism
the father it's actually from the book
mm-hmm can you please elaborate more on
that because I try to give it my own
meaning but I couldn't show it gosh
these are pretty yeah you were remark
how simple this actually is when you see
is a great historian by the name of
Barbra fields who wrote this book called
Racecraft and she you know I think lays
it out pretty well and and you know
again this was one of the books that
helped clarify things for me okay so um
Americans generally believe that the
problem in terms of racism in this
country is that you have a few or
several different disparate groups who
do not get along and one of those groups
has more power than than the other and
that if we could just get the groups to
get along everything will be okay this
is the theory of race and its benevolent
theory right here's how we talk about
you know it's in our vocabulary racial
relations for instance as though there's
a you know race here race in if we can
improve relations between them
everything will be okay racial
discrimination you know there's a race
of people over here if we could just
stop doing certain things to that
specific race of people everything would
be okay and so the racism comes after
okay the racism exists and you're doing
something to you know a race of people
and that act is racism but the race
itself already exists it's a real thing
it's a demonstrable thing it's an
obvious thing that is built on a notion
the black people themselves are a race
of people that come out of Africa and
white people themselves are a race of
people that come out of Europe in Asians
Americans are a race of people that come
out of Asia and Native Americans are a
race of people that you know have lived
here you know for a long time let's say
and increasingly that Hispanics and
Latinos are a race of people that
somehow originated I don't know in the
past 50 years or so I don't
it just happened they just became a race
we got a race now there's another race
and if all these races could get along
then we could somehow fulfill the
promise of a matter that that actually
is the problem that's the notion that
dead death that in fact it race is the
parent and racism results because these
groups can't you know get along with
each other one group keeps doing
something to another group or whatever
but that's not how history actually
works
there is no coherent a definition of
race be that white be that black be that
Latino asian-american however that you
can maintain across time and geography
and this is easily demonstrable okay I
am considered a black person right here
right if I were in Louisiana and say
1750 I might not be considered that if I
were living in New Orleans
if I were in Brazil I might check some
whole other block if I were living in
apartheid South Africa I might check
college for instance we know that when
Irish people came to this country when
people came from Italy to this country
Jewish people came to this country we
know that they were viewed in varying
degrees as being white they certainly
weren't immediately accepted as white we
know this we know there was a political
process but which suddenly these groups
of people became white but it wasn't
their mere arrival and everything was
okay
in fact we even know that different
quote-unquote races of people by which I
mean you know some people having a
darker darker skin and hailing from
sub-saharan Africa have actually been in
interaction with people who have fair
skin and living your foot for some time
throughout our history and we know that
the relationship has not always been the
relationship that that it was right now
we know that for instance you know
during the state of the 14th century to
15th century the primary threat at least
in the mind of quote-unquote Europeans
and even now that word is wrong was in
fact the Turks or Muslims and he
constructed themselves as being part of
Christendom and we know that in Africa
you know suddenly you know if you were a
member of ethnic group you did not
consider yourself black there was no
to think of yourself as a black boys
part of a racist this is a modern
invention and when it begins to happen
it's when you see a need in the Western
Hemisphere for labor and for folks to be
carried across you know oceans so that
they can label on the behalf of other
folks and there is a need to justify
that labor and you can literally see
this you know you read Edna Morgan's
American slavery of American freedom you
can see the laws literally changing you
can see the first group of African
slaves enslaved Africans coming to this
country in 1619 in the early 17th
century and actually intermixing with
indentured servants in a marrying in
fact having kids together doing what
human beings you know do and you know
they're really being no laws against
sister you know people not looking at
them thinking that's an abomination all
of that came later and it came later
because certain laws were passed so that
you could maximize the amount of
enslaved labor that you could possibly
have there is no reason why one drop is
nothing biological about a one drop rule
at all nothing that rule comes out of
the notion of having as many enslaved
people as possible
so what I'm trying to get you guys is
that it was an actual process it was a
done thing this is not the Word of God
this is not even science this is a
decision that was made this was
literally laws that were passed policy
made to decide who's black and who was a
black man Plessy vs. Ferguson plus it
was like James Bennett's complexion but
he had some distant African you know I
said somewhere in there you know and
literally in the case of guy rights you
know what listen I'm not here to figure
out whether this dude is black or not
you know it's not really what was up cuz
he couldn't I mean there's no coherent
definition of it if someone United
Stated in that way you get that we made
this world and it's wrong with that is
that mean that means you have some
responsibility and even in a bill and a
ability and ability to unmake the world
to make it different it really is on us
you know this is not some curse that
somebody else gave us we did this so I
think it's like really important to
realize that so that you know is a long
way of saying
where's the graces of the child of
racism not the father
here's a short and very interesting
question I think how if at all would
this book have been different if you had
a daughter that's impossible to say or
an actual yeah I mean I had 15 years
with Samari and I smile reflects into 15
years with Samar I don't have a daughter
I can't no I can't no now that you're
living in Paris
are you considering writing about race
relations there now that we're very far
from its role as a haven for black
Americans maybe nor reflect on that it's
not so great for minorities these days
very few places in the world that are
great for minorities who knows that's
part of the definition of a minority you
know unless it's an oppressive minority
until you can you have that sometimes
too but in general in a quote/unquote
democracy ten things tend not to be all
that great for minorities so just a word
on this I like France I like Paris I
like baguettes I like wine I like cheese
I love Paris like I love New York you
know and I do love New York
do I love New York because I think
there's no racism in New York no you
know I love doing this I love the West
Village because I love Brooklyn in the
eyes that's why I cuz I love Harlem
that's why I love New York and it's no
different when parents Paris is just a
place it's not um an escape or at least
it's not an escape in that sense it is
different in the sense that when I speak
my bad French people recognize me as
American and the first thing they see is
dumb American you know Anissa takes
precedence you know in their mind at
least over you know my skin color my
skin color by the way my skin colors in
African America and not other you know
Africans who you know or descendants of
Africans who lived and speak French and
you know perfectly fluently my skin
colors as an African American so it is
in fact
a different feeling but I think on one
hand the need to say like well France is
less racist than America and on the
other hand the need to say what in fact
France is actually much more racist but
it does XYZ said I think you're in the
wrong game I think that's that's s a
fool's errand from jump I think the
thing to do is try to observe what the
society is actually doing you know use
it as as a standard of itself
I don't like observe America and think
about racism in America you know in in
comparison really to other places and
that's a--that's not really my goal I'm
trying to see the country in and of
itself and you know I would expect to do
the same thing with France although you
know it's impossible to avoid making
some comparisons but I hope those
comparisons will not be you know as mean
as you know a French people do racism
like this and Americans do race like
this I hope to get something a little
deeper than that you know there's not a
single question in here about comic
books I was leaving that to you guys I
assumed somebody was nasty
Black Panther but it's not here staying
overseas for a second than this
questioner says that Shearer he's an
immigrant from Africa how can we
continue to make genuine solidarity
between african-american community and
African communities I don't know I'm
gonna disappoint on that that question
I'm not sure I have you know spent my
time studying like really really
specific things the African American
experience in this country is broth is
textured is multiple layered and it is
very very hard to have any sort of
general expertise in it you know you can
have some sort of knowledge and specific
areas you start talking about the
Diaspora you know and it becomes even
that much harder you know so the
question like I immediately go to so
what do we mean by Africans do we meet
you know solidarity with Ethiopians we
mean solidarity with South Africans with
Senegalese with Ghanaians
different you know Ghana has this
program now where African Americans can
go there and get citizenship does that
you know mean something different is
there some sort of different
relationship there can we generalize it
in that broad sort of way that's not to
insult the question at all you know it's
a decent question but I think it's one
that you know requires study will
requires study from me you know require
more than I know right now to actually
you know intelligently answer all right
this questioner says not sure if you
know the history of this neighborhood
Fort Greene asked Spike Lee but many
poor people of color were displaced to
make this area beautiful and safe enough
for quote us unquote how can we respond
how do you to gentrification by
advocating for reparations it's just a
funny word to say black people have less
wealth than white people I mean it's
just I mean it that really is the bottom
line
it would not neighborly to change all
the time in you know that you know
makeup and ethnic makeup
the problem is black people don't really
have the same level of
self-determination to decide whether
they want to stay and whether they want
to leave and the reason why they don't
is because you know and this is just you
know the clearest example I can offer we
have a huge huge wild gap in this
country for every nickel of wealth that
an African American family has a white
family has a dollar 20 times the wealth
what expectation should there be that
folks can live where they want or can
have the same so the choice about where
they want to live as other folks when
it's that big of a wealth gap you know I
know that all sorts of programs
affordable housing and all the things
you know maybe making it easy for folks
to buy homes etc but until you get to
that root problem that huge wealth gap
which is the result of policy which is
not the result of magic
which is not the result of science was
its result about a particular kind of
social science and social engineering
but it is the result of decisions that
we made when we built the middle class
in this country that made this case
before we made decisions about who was
gonna benefit from the kind of social
engineering we were going to practice to
offer people the ability to build wealth
through home loans this is a principal
way you know we built down the middle a
lot of middle class and we decided black
people weren't a part of that and not
only that individual black people were
not going to be a part of that but whole
blocks where black people moved would
not be a part of that how would Harlem
look if we hadn't have done that
how about Fort Greene look if we hadn't
have done that how a bed-stuy look if we
hadn't have done that
what would this city look like if
African Americans had the same access to
the social safety net when we made all
those great reforms in the 40s and in
the late 30s what would be the
difference then who the world have
looked like if we had not you know made
a decision to only offer unionized labor
to certain people what would the world
look like what is the percentage of
African Americans on the fire department
right now I know they didn't make some
efforts but at one point it was like
some depressingly low number what would
the world have looked like without that
discrimination my argument ends as you
know it's been out of late the data adds
up and so when you start on the level of
like looking at Fort Greene and saying
you know what what the hell is going on
here how come black folks can't hold
hold doin anything here but see it was
game set and match like 20 30 40 50
years ago you're too late you know you
are in the fourth quarter with two
minutes left and you're trying to you
know win the game and you're on your own
two yard line and you're saying why am I
on my own two yard line with only two
minutes left
Missy that was a whole you know third
quarter second quarter first quarter
there was a game
that happened before that if you start
with the analysis right there you've
missed it you've missed it and so you
know I think like when we get to the
point of talking about gentrification
you know like you got to dig deep you
have to go further back it didn't start
here you know your expectation that
certain folks will show it to this
neighborhood decide they want to live
here and that black folks will be able
to have that same sort of deciding power
given the past history of housing policy
in this country makes no sense you know
gentrification is is you know not so
much lamentable as it is predictable
ease is what will happen period some
folks will have more choice about where
they want to live other than others
because that was our policy for so long
in the 20th century to limit the ability
of black people to have the sort of
decisions that other folks in this
country do so what it what I mean
for green is predictable in that sense
here's a here's maybe a tougher or pain
question a good one maybe for you to
address before New York audience about
the book you mentioned firefighters a
minute ago you wrote in your book that
the firefighters who died at the Twin
Towers were not human to you do you
still feel that way no no I mean the
book is you know almost like about how I
felt at the time and um that that part
of book comes after my friend Prince
Jones has been killed so the prince was
killed September of 2000 my son was born
in August and that's you know just a
huge thing that a book turns on my
friends killed by a police officer
police officer wasn't prosecuted wet and
fired nothing happened it's just like
whatever he was mistaken for some other
suspected criminal who charges were
never even brought against he was
followed from the suburbs of Maryland
into Washington DC out into Virginia and
he was shot near yards from his
fiancee's house his mother Mabel Jones
you know as I detailed in a book had
worked herself up from gray
poverty was the child of sharecroppers
gone off to college served in the Navy
went to med school become a radiologist
had done everything that you know you
you're supposed to do in America to you
know improve yourself and a child was
just shot down they did nothing that you
know nothing came of it
if someone 9/11 happened that's all that
great pageantry you know for the police
for the firefighters and you know even
the victims to be frank with you
I just felt cold I had nothing for
anyone and not even any any any victims
at all I couldn't see them as human as I
say in the book because what made their
deaths any more worthy of commemoration
than the death of Prince Jones I
couldn't understand it surely they were
victims of terrorism but my friend was a
victim of a kind of terrorism that is as
old as this country and there was
nothing for him that was how I felt then
one of the things that happens though is
um you know you what you get older
that's the first thing that happens and
what are getting old is that you can
explain your pain then you can explain
why you feel a certain way but that
don't make it right you know say it's
like I can explain to you why riot
happened right why riots happen but that
doesn't make like burning a CVS down
correct you know the New York Times
published a series probably about three
years after 9/11 and the series was
specifically on the fire department and
it sought to talk about like the
decisions that happened that day and why
folks you know went into the buildings
because the fire department had you know
just a level of casualties I was beyond
even a police department and they did it
in such a way every you know it wasn't
like this big thing like firefighters it
was this guys like Joe this guy right
here with a wife with a kid you know I
mean with you know people that loved him
you know with people that hated him you
know I came to regard the destruction of
individual life as a tragedy and it does
not matter how other people commemorate
that you know my beef with other folks
and how do you observe that has nothing
to do with whether I can have some level
of empathy with the destruction of
individual life those are two separate
things now I can talk about you know
hypocrisy up up one side down the other
I can talk about my pain one side down
but it does not improve me
did they not be able to see you know
folks whose lives were taken from them
as human yeah that was a process that
that took my I certainly did not feel
that way at the top there's the third so
many good questions in here
unfortunately I think I can ask one more
and then we need to bring it to a close
and this is maybe a good point and the
number of people are asking about your
sources of inspiration and and how you
write and this question maybe brings
this conversation full circle a little
bit to where you started it some which
comes which comes first when you sit
down to write political intention or
artistic intention art or they want in
this nation artistic intention hmm
artistic intention always it's not right
about things that are not necessarily
political you always want to write
beautifully that's for me it makes me
feel good about the world all right I
think we'll leave it there Tennessee
[Applause]
[Music]